[MUSIC PLAYING]
PHILIP NEL: So was the
Cat in the Hat black,
and what on earth do I
mean by that question?
I mean, he's a cat, isn't he?
Sure, he's a cartoon
cat who walks upright,
who wears a red and
white striped top
hat and a kind of garish bow
tie and carries an umbrella,
but he's a cat--
probably.
Maybe?
I'll answer my title
question in a moment.
But first, I should
say that I've
made the question, the title
question, because, as Robin
Bernstein has noted, racism
sneaks into children's culture
under the cloak of
innocence, and once there, it
continues to influence
the broader culture.
I've made this the
title of the book
because racial and
racist images persist
in the cultures of
childhood, often in ways
that we don't notice
on a conscious level.
This is why in children's
books and culture,
race is present, especially
when it seems to be absent.
And Dr. Seuss's
"The Cat in the Hat"
illuminates the ways in
which images from the past
continue to haunt the present
and apparently discarded
racial ideas linger on.
"The Cat in the Hat" is
racially complicated,
inspired by blackface caricature
and by actual people of color.
One story of the
book's origins is
that in 1955, William Spaulding,
director of Houghton Mifflin's
educational division, thought
that Dr. Seuss could solve
the "Why Johnny Can't Read"
crisis by writing reading
primers that children actually
enjoyed reading, instead
of Dick and Jane, which
children did not enjoy reading.
So as Seuss rode the elevator
up to Spaulding's office,
he noticed that the
elevator operator
was an elegant, petite
African-American woman who
wore white gloves
and a secret smile.
Her name was Annie
Williams, and in response
to Spaulding's challenge--
"Write me a story that first
graders can't put down"--
Seuss wrote "The
Cat in the Hat,"
giving the protagonist Mrs.
Williams's white gloves,
her sly smile, and her color.
A source for the
cat's red bow tie
is Krazy Kat, the
ambiguously gendered creation
of biracial cartoonist
George Herriman.
Seuss also draws on the
traditions of minstrelsy,
an influence that emerges
first in a minstrel show
that he wrote and performed
in in blackface while
in high school.
In fact, blackface
minstrelsy recurs
in Seuss's early cartoons, in
20th century popular culture,
and its traces linger
on in many other icons
of children's literature.
As Robin Bernstein says--
I'm going to quote
her here at length--
"Children's culture
has a special ability
to preserve even as it
distorts and transmit
even as it fragments the
blackface mask and styles
of movement which persist
not only in Raggedy
Ann and the Scarecrow but also
in the faces and gloved hands
of Mickey Mouse and Bugs Bunny."
And to her list we
can add Seuss's cat.
And what makes the
cat so interesting
and so representative-- and why
he's the title of the book--
is that during the
very same decade
that "The Cat in the
Hat" was published,
Seuss was both speaking
out against racism
and recycling racist
caricature in his books.
So in a 1952 essay, he pointedly
critiques racist humor.
In 1953, inspired by his
opposition to anti-Semitism,
he writes "The Sneetches."
And then, the same
year as Brown v. Board
of Education, the
landmark Supreme Court
case that ostensibly made school
segregation illegal in the US,
"Horton Hears a Who"
presents the Whos' smallness
as an arbitrary mark of
difference for which they
are unfairly penalized.
One review at the time said
that Horton's refrain--
"A person's a person,
no matter how small"--
was, quote, "a rhymed lesson
in protection of minorities
and their rights."
And yet, in the same decade,
in "If I Ran the Zoo,"
Gerald McGrew proposes going
to the African island of Yerka
to bring back a
tizzle-topped Tufted
Mazurka, who sits on a perch
carried by two African men.
And suggesting a kinship with
animals, the two nearly naked
Africans have tufts
on their heads
that resemble the tuft
on the head of the bird.
Their faces really
seem to come straight
out of Seuss's early cartoons.
The same book offers a
visit to "the mountains
of Zomba-ma-Tant
with helpers who
wear their eyes at a slant."
Meanwhile, "Scrambled Eggs
Super!", also from the '50s,
invites us to laugh at Ali, a
gullible Arab being attacked
by hundreds of angry Mt.
Strookoo Cuckoos.
Dr. Seuss's work is both
racist and opposes racism
and does both in
the same decade.
These characters and the
cat's minstrel ancestry
reveal Seuss's
racial unconscious,
indicating how his
imagination resuscitated
and revised early 20th century
and 19th century stereotypes.
His career also reminds us that
you don't need to be a Klansman
or, say, Donald Trump, to
participate in white supremacy.
Recognizing the Cat
in the Hat's ancestry
in both blackface performance
and African-American culture
makes visible three ways in
which American picture books
have been a battleground in
the fight against racism.
First, just as recognizing
how black voices shaped
"Huckleberry Finn," the book
from which I stole my title,
helps us to desegregate
American children's literature--
American literature, excuse me--
so understanding how black
voices and blackface created
Seuss's "The Cat in
the Hat" assists us
in desegregating
children's literature.
Seuss's work is not only heir
to the nonsense of Lewis Carroll
and Edward Lear
and Hilaire Belloc,
it's also heir to that of E.
W. Campbell in its stereotypes
and Langston Hughes in opposing
those same stereotypes.
Second, in the '50s,
American readers
of children's literature
saw animal characters
as distinctly racialized.
In fact, in both racist
and anti-racist children's
literature, differences
between animals
have had a long
history of representing
differences between and
similarities among races.
So in 1959, racist
Southerners accused this book,
Garth Williams's "The
Rabbits' Wedding,"
of promoting integration and
demanded that the book be
removed from libraries.
In the book a white rabbit
marries a black rabbit.
This became a national
news story at the time.
The third reason for
thinking about the cat's
minstrel ancestry
is that borrowing
from American iconography,
the Cat in the Hat
and the minstrel both dramatize
the moral contradictions
at the heart of
the United States,
a country founded both on
slavery and, paradoxically,
on the idea of freedom.
As a response to the "Why
Johnny Can't Read" crisis,
the cat offered the hope that
his exciting, poetic narrative
would make literacy available
to all American children.
But despite Brown v.
Board of Education
three years before,
libraries remained
segregated in most states.
Black students don't have
access to the same materials
that white students had.
So if the cat represents all
American children's right
to literacy, he also masks
a separate but unequal
educational system.
He embodies the discrepancy
between the ideals
and the realities of America
in the 1950s and today,
which is why "Was the
Cat in the Hat Black?"
is the title of the book.
But-- and I'm sorry
to disappoint here--
the book is not only
about Dr. Seuss.
Really, only the first
chapter focuses on Dr. Seuss.
Each chapter of "Was the
Cat in the Hat Black?"
addresses the often unseen
ways in which racism persists
in children's literature.
Racism endures because
racism is structural.
It's embedded in culture,
embedded in institutions.
And my argument-- and
I'm not the first person
to make this argument-- is that
one of the places that racism
hides and one of the
best places to oppose it
is books for young people.
What we learn as children
shapes our world views
so profoundly because
when we are small,
we are still in the process
of figuring out who we are
and what we believe.
For this reason, children's
books, children's toys,
and children's culture are
some of the most important
influences on who we
become and on what biases
we harbor or don't harbor.
And so we need to
ask hard questions
and have uncomfortable
conversations
about the children's books
and children's culture
that we consume.
And this will be
upsetting for some people.
Dr. Seuss Enterprises
for example,
the corporate entity that
oversees the licensing
and production of
all things Seuss,
would really, really prefer
that Seuss's own racism
not be discussed.
When I wrote the official
biography for the Seussville
website, I was asked to cut
any mention of stereotypes
in the cartoons, even though my
narrative tried to frame this
in a positive way, noting
that in his later work Seuss
actively opposed stereotypes,
which he did and also didn't.
Since I wanted to
be paid for the job,
I cut that, although
I have included
that story in this book
and right now in this talk.
Seuss Enterprises' resistance
exemplifies the problem.
The failure to discuss
our work honestly
helps sustain racism in
children's literature
and culture.
To borrow the words
of Robin DiAngelo,
who I'll come to again
later in the talk,
"A continual retreat
from the discomfort
of authentic racial
engagement results
in a perpetual cycle that
works to hold racism in place."
And if we're ever
to break that cycle,
we need to experience
that discomfort,
to have those uncomfortable
conversations.
And this may seem
counterintuitive,
but I argue that actually,
racist classics of children's
literature can help us initiate
those uncomfortable but
necessary conversations.
Now, I completely
understand why people
would want to erase the racism
from books for young people,
changing the offensive portions
of "Huck Finn," "Charlie
and the Chocolate Factory,"
"Doctor Doolittle," "Mary
Poppins," and many other books--
which is something that
happens, by the way,
in children's literature.
Books get changed, get altered
to try to clean them up.
And this seems to
offer us a way to keep
a literary work
available and accessible
without inflicting harm
upon young readers.
And to be clear, racist texts
can inflict real psychic damage
on children of all races.
But the child who is a
member of the targeted group
bears a much heavier burden
than the child who is not.
The racism in these books all
but ensure that children who
are and have historically been
the targets of prejudice will
suffer in ways that
white children won't.
So the 1988 edition of
Lofting's "Doctor Doolittle"
removes all references
to skin color
and Prince Bumpo no
longer wishes to be white.
The bird Polynesia instead
tricks him through hypnosis.
In 1973, Roald Dahl
revised his own "Charlie
and the Chocolate Factory."
Instead of African
Pygmies, the Oompa-Loompas
become small white
people from Oompaland.
P. L. Travers rewrote
the "Bad Tuesday" chapter
of "Mary Poppins" twice, in
1967 to remove the dialect
from the people that
they meet as they travel
around the world, and in
1981 to remove the people
and replace them with animals.
And quite famously,
fairly recently,
Alan Gribben's 2011 edition of
"The Adventures of Huckleberry
Finn" replaces all instances
of "nigger" with "slave"
and all instances of
"Injun" with "Indian."
And that is a lot of changes.
Twain uses the n-word 219
times in "Huckleberry Finn."
And for this very reason,
there is a very strong case
to be made for removing
racist books from grade
school and high school
curricula altogether.
Julius Lester, for example, has
said that he is "grateful that
among the many indignities
inflicted on me in childhood,
I escaped 'Huckleberry Finn.'"
He adds that as a black parent,
he sympathizes with those
who want the book banned,
or at least removed from
required reading lists
in schools.
In fact, we can develop his
line of argument even further
and argue that the best
way to hasten the decline
of a racist classic and thus
the racism that it may propagate
is just not to teach
it at all at any level.
And that's a strong argument,
and I respect that argument.
I'm going to make a slightly
different argument here,
and that is that
ignoring the symptoms
does not cure the
disease and that it
is more risky to ban the
racist books outright
or to use only the
bowdlerized editions.
And for those who may not
know the term, to "bowdlerize"
is to clean up an
offensive text.
The term comes from
Thomas Bowdler,
who did this to
Shakespeare 200 years ago
and created "The
Family Shakespeare,"
a Shakespeare for children
that would not provide
them inappropriate material.
So rather than bowdlerize,
rather than edit these books,
I think it's a less risky
choice to teach them critically,
helping students see the ways
in which the books reinforce
racism and engaging in
painful, but I think necessary,
conversations.
And this is why, just
as popular characters
like the Cat in the Hat,
Mickey Mouse, and Bugs Bunny
naturalize their own
minstrel origins,
so bowdlerized versions
of classic books
normalize the racism that
revisionists aspire to expunge.
Attempts to erase
racism from these books
don't actually get rid
of racist ideologies.
They just make them
more insidious.
They make them less obvious and
thus more difficult to resist.
So in the revised
version of "Charlie
and the Chocolate Factory,"
the Oompa-Loompas still happily
acquiesce to being shipped to
England in large packing cases,
and they find life in
a factory preferable
to life in their native land.
They still submit to
enslavement happily.
Similarly, removing
references to skin color
in "Doctor Doolittle" does
not also remove colonialism.
Dr. Doolittle remains an
enlightened white European who
goes to civilize the natives.
In all cases, trying
to remove the racism
and colonialism just more
subtly encodes the same racial
and colonial messages.
Cleaning up these texts
just makes those messages
harder to spot and
harder to oppose.
So a better
approach, I think, is
to read the originals with
children-- and of course,
in the context of other
books that present racism
and present
colonialism critically.
Here are three
benefits of doing so.
First, as Brigitte Fielder
noted after I presented
a version of this
chapter at a conference,
"The decision to
talk about racism
is a position of privilege."
I mention this
because some people
may question the wisdom
of talking about racism
with young children.
But that is a
question or a comment
that comes from privilege,
because since children of color
face racism from their earliest
days, the adults in their lives
don't have the choice of whether
to discuss racism with them.
The subject will come up,
and responsible adults
will also bring it up in
the hopes of improving
the children's safety.
Parents tell black children,
especially their sons,
only walk in the street
with one boy at a time,
because if it's three
or more, you're a mob.
That's how the
police will see you.
They tell them never to
ask the police for help.
They say, don't run
or they'll shoot you.
And if children
of color are going
to survive in America
and the larger world,
they'll need to learn
how to respond to racism.
And discussing racism via the
safer realm of children's books
can prepare them to face it in
the world beyond the classroom.
Second, teaching
racist children's books
can help direct the anger
of those readers who
are racism's targets.
If, when facing racist art,
children do not learn how
to express anger or where
to direct their anger,
they may be left only with
a pain that they cannot
articulate.
Finding the appropriate
target for one's anger
is a vital survival skill.
As Martha Nussbaum points
out, submerged anger
can emerge as depression.
However, expressed anger can
be vital for developing agency.
As Nico Fridja notes,
"Anger implies hope.
Further, anger implies that
fighting is meaningful;
one is not reduced
to mere passivity."
And I'm not arguing
for tough love here.
Suffering is not ennobling.
I am arguing that
children understand
more than they can articulate
and that without the ability
to name or diagnose what
they have experienced,
they risk, in the words
of Mari J. Matsuda,
"internalizing the injury done
them and being rendered silent
in the face of
continuing injury."
And I must again stress here
that racist novels must only
be read in context.
So to expose the illusion of
kindly white slave-owning Uncle
Silas and the kind
but gullible Jim
in "The Adventures
of Huckleberry Finn,"
readers might turn to realistic
novels like Christopher Paul
Curtis's "Elijah of Buxton,"
where slavers are murderers
and torturers, and where
Canada, not America, is
the land of the free.
Or they might read "To Be
a Slave," Julius Lester's
powerful collection of
ex-slaves' narratives, where
they'll learn of living
quarters, quote, "more
fit for animals
than human beings,
mothers who kill
their own children
rather than allow
them to be sold,
and other ways that slaves
resisted their white masters."
And third, a
critical examination
of racist children's books
while readers are still children
may prevent youthful
affection from curdling
into adult nostalgia.
Grownups' emotional
relationships
with the works of
their childhood
often clouds their perception.
Fondness can deflect
critical questions.
In contrast, asking children
questions about these books
while they're children can
create a different, more
critically engaged, more
uncomfortable relationship,
because children's emotional
relationships with these books
are still developing,
still open ended.
The need to read and
to teach these books
is an argument that I make
with reluctance and sadness.
All children should
be granted a childhood
free from the
injuries of prejudice.
However, since encounters with
hate are sadly inevitable,
literature can offer us a
safer space for young people
to explore the complex, the
difficult, the painful emotions
that racism elicits.
Both shielding children
from and exposing children
to racist texts are bad choices,
but failing to confront racism
is far more dangerous
than ignoring it.
Indeed, learning how
to respond to racism
is especially
important for children
in Donald Trump's
America, which has
made overt racism more
socially acceptable than it
has been in decades.
According to the Southern
Poverty Law Center's 2016 study
"The Trump Effect,"
over 2/3 of educators
reported that young
people in their schools--
immigrants, children of
immigrants, Muslims, African
Americans, and other
students of color--
had expressed concern
about what might happen
to them or their families,
and since the election,
hate crimes and racist
harassment in school grounds
have only increased.
The Trump candidacy
and presidency
have required all good
teachers to discuss racism
in the classroom.
And it may surprise you,
but these discussions
can also take place where
racism doesn't actually
seem to be a core
issue of the work,
or where racial politics and
race itself don't seem present.
However, the stories in
which race seems to disappear
are often those where racism is
embedded more subtly and more
dangerously.
So William Joyce's "The
Fantastic Flying Books
of Mr. Morris Lessmore" is a
case study of this phenomenon.
It's an Oscar-winning
animated short.
It became an electronic
book app and a picture book.
And it is an aesthetic marvel.
It may be the only
children's story
that I know of that works
equally brilliantly as a book,
as an app, and as a film.
It's also really, really white.
And this is strange,
because Hurricane Katrina,
a main inspiration
for the story,
killed nearly 2,000 people,
and most of those people,
as you probably know,
were African Americans.
Throughout New Orleans,
African-American victims
outnumbered white victims
by more than double,
comprising 66% of
the storm deaths,
while whites made up only 31%.
And the storm displaced
many more people.
But with the exception
of a portrait
of Duke Ellington
hanging on the wall
and glimpsed very briefly near
the end of both app and film,
there are otherwise no
characters of color anywhere
in the app, in the
film, or the book.
And the conspicuous racial
absence in this story
and in Joyce's body
of work more generally
highlight how structural racism
works in children's literature.
It tends to normalize
whiteness, tends
to dwell in nostalgia,
to exoticize,
to demonize, or just to erase
non-white people altogether.
Morris Lessmore also represents
technological innovation's
propensity for distracting us
from the racial assumptions
that underwrite its success.
Morris Lessmore's
acclaim depends in part
upon the way it makes race
disappear beneath whiteness's
invisibility cloak.
Unacknowledged
whiteness is the midwife
to all ostensibly
transcendent timeless stories.
Culturally unmarked
white characters
read as universal characters.
And so in Joyce's work, the
displaced people are all white.
The white title character
becomes caretaker and librarian
of a beautiful library
whose patrons are all white
and whose books are
all by white authors.
So despite Morris Lessmore's
declaration in both app
and picture book that
everyone's story matters,
Joyce's own story
emphatically disagrees.
Even more troubling is that
Joyce's larger body of work
either omits people of
color or includes them only
as exotic secondary characters.
So in "Dinosaur Bob and
the Family Lazardo,"
Jumbu, their bodyguard, said
nothing is a running gag,
recurring three times.
Jumbu's only speech
in the book is a smile
on the final two-page spread.
His name, his
costume, and his role
as a servant to a
white American family
makes him an exotic other.
And more troubling
is Joyce's tendency
to shade his villains in dark
colors, such as the attacking
army of dark elves
in "Santa Calls."
In images that resemble
1930s magazine illustrations,
Joyce's imaginative
nostalgic vision
subtly reinscribes early 20th
century ideologies of race
while effacing a
history underwritten
by those same ideologies.
And having said all
that, I actually
understand why nostalgia might
inspire "The Fantastic Flying
Books of Mr. Morris Lessmore."
After the storm
moved the New Orleans
that Joyce knew from
contemporary time
into the receding
tide of memory,
it's actually not
surprising that longing
for the pre-Katrina city
would find itself expressed
in nostalgic reconstruction.
Located where today dreams
of forgotten yesterdays,
nostalgia is itself
a crossroads,
with paths leading to childhood,
creativity, and sorrow,
all of which are central
concerns of Morris
Lessmore and its creator.
As Linda Hutcheon suggests, ever
since nostalgia shifted from
a physical condition-- it
was originally a diagnosis
for severe homesickness--
to a psychological
one, nostalgia
has been yoked to childhood.
In 1798, Immanuel Kant noticed
of nostalgia sufferers,
Hutcheon tells us, that
people who did return home
were usually disappointed,
because in fact they
did not want to
return to a place
but to a time, a time of youth.
So that the author
of a children's story
might revive earlier
aesthetic motifs, possibly
images encountered
in his own childhood,
not only resonates
with Kant's insight
but also recalls the
connections between creativity
and nostalgia.
So the problem is actually
not that Joyce is nostalgic.
The problem, I think, is
his type of nostalgia.
And to explain what
I mean, I'm going
to borrow Svetlana Boym's
very useful distinction
between different
kinds of nostalgia.
She distinguishes between
restorative nostalgia
and reflectiveness nostalgia.
And Joyce's work, I
think, cloaks the former
in the latter.
As Boym writes,
"Restorative nostalgia
does not think of itself
as nostalgia, but rather
as truth and tradition.
Reflective nostalgia
dwells on the ambivalences
of human longing and
belonging and does not
shy away from the
contradictions of modernity.
Restorative nostalgia
protects the absolute truth,
while reflective nostalgia
calls it into doubt."
And visually, "Morris Lessmore"
does resemble this reflective
nostalgia, lingering
on, to quote Boym here,
"ruins, the patina
of time and history,
and the dreams of another
place, another time."
However, ideologically,
it seems to yearn
for that trans-historical
reconstruction characteristic
of restorative nostalgia.
It imagines the past where in
the midst of a pastoral idyll,
a library's open door invites
a white reader onto beautifully
polished hardwood floors, where
he can peruse stacks of books
by white authors and loan
some of them to white readers.
Now to be clear, I don't think
that William Joyce himself
is consciously nostalgic
for white supremacy.
I've never met the man.
Seems like a nice guy.
Rather, I think that a memory
steeped in a white supremacist
culture--
and we live in a white
supremacist culture--
cannot easily filter
out the racist bits.
I also think that because
aesthetics are bound up
in emotions, this type of
restorative nostalgia cannot
easily be repelled or refuted.
When the imagination
mingles racist imagery
or racial erasures with a
deep yearning for childhood,
these strands become very
difficult to disentangle.
In other words, the unconscious
racism of restorative nostalgia
tends to resist analysis.
Creators and audiences insist
that because they are not
personally racist, their
affection for the work
repudiates any allegation
that it might contain
even trace elements of racism.
The absence of non-white
characters, for example,
often gets interpreted as
evidence that the artist simply
does not see race, and thus his
characters' whiteness is really
a mark of his objectivity.
But whiteness's power
derives from its ability
to figure white people
as ideologically
neutral, as the human
race instead of as white.
And works that ask us to read
their population of exclusively
white characters as merely
normal, universal people
assert white
dominance via not just
the erasure of non-white people
but the denial of race itself.
So the absence of
characters of color
in Joyce's and other
white creators' works--
and this is a case study here.
Lots of people do this.
It's not just William Joyce.
But this absence of
sympathetic characters of color
perpetuates failures
of the imagination.
When children primarily consume
culture that distorts or omits
people like them, their
psyches become damaged.
The Nigerian-born contemporary
novelist Chimamanda Ngozi
Adichie has spoken
eloquently of the effect
that a childhood
spent reading British
and American children's
books had on her.
When she began writing her own
stories at the age of seven,
she tells us, "All my characters
were white and blue-eyed.
They played in the snow.
They ate apples.
And they talked a lot
about the weather.
How lovely it was that
the sun had come out.
Now, this despite the fact
that I lived in Nigeria.
I'd never been outside Nigeria.
We didn't have snow.
We ate mangoes.
And we didn't talk
about the weather,
because there was no need to."
And she says her young
experience, quote,
"shows how impressionable
and vulnerable
we are in the face of a story,
particularly as children.
Because all I had read were
books in which the characters
were foreign, I had
become convinced
that books, by
their very nature,
had to have foreigners in them.
They had to be about things with
which I could not personally
identify."
And so, she says, one unintended
consequence was that, quote,
"I did not know that people like
me could exist in literature."
And whether we call this process
"the danger of a single story"
or "colonizing the
imagination," it
demonstrates that racial
invisibility actually
is as harmful as
racial stereotyping.
And such erasures are
not limited to works
with all-white casts, either.
Publishers can even perform
racial vanishing acts
on books featuring
characters of color.
In the interest of time, I've
cut this whitewashing chapter
from the presentation
today, but briefly, this
is what it's about.
Believing that books with a
person of color on the cover
will not sell,
publishers will instead
put a white face or a silhouette
or an ambiguously-raced face
on the dust jacket of a book
whose protagonist is not white.
And this is
important, because we
do judge books by their covers.
Those that render people
of color invisible
tell them that
their experiences--
tell young people of color
that their experiences are not
important enough to read about.
And young readers notice.
So to address the
problem of racism
in children's
literature, we have
to change the way
that it is produced.
Right now, 89% of people
employed in the publishing
industry identify as
white or Caucasian.
Only 5% identify as Asian,
3% as Hispanic, and 1%
as African American.
And those numbers do not
represent the population
at large, nor do the books
that are published every year.
Though half of US school-aged
students are children of color,
only 14% of American children's
books published in 2015
were about people
of color, and then
the number by people
of color was even less.
It was only 10%.
And if you look more closely,
you'll notice something else--
that realism, historical
novels, and nonfiction more
generally tend to be the most
popular genre categories.
In American children's and
young adult publishing,
genre works as a
kind of Jim Crow.
It's a "non-racial" way
of regulating the literary
experiences of people of color.
Where 50 years ago,
people of color
were almost entirely excluded
from mainstream publishing,
now they get to
publish, but just
in a few select neighborhoods,
the borders of which
can be mapped by genre.
There are many examples of this.
Walter Dean Myers
is one example.
Or as Malinda Lo
has noted, quote,
"There can be a zillion
white authors who
write whatever kind of book,
but if one marginalized author
exists who does
it, that's enough."
And you don't get
a chance to do it.
And there are countless
stories like these.
And until recently,
these are what we've had.
We've had these stories.
We haven't really had data.
But in February of
2015, the University
of Wisconsin's Cooperative
Children's Book Center,
which does a fantastic
job of tracking
how many diverse books
get published every year,
for the first time posted
a list of all the titles
in its annual African-American
and American Indian categories
for the books of that year.
It didn't list titles in any
other categories and it hasn't
done this since, but I read
reviews of all the books,
and in some cases the books
themselves, counted which
books fit in which genres--
of course, all books fit
in more than one genre,
so my percentages
don't add up to 100.
But these are the patterns of
the 193 books in the African,
African-American list.
34% are realism, 30%
have a historical focus,
and 10% are biographies.
All the other genres
crowd together
in a much smaller space.
Now, the fact that books in
other genres do get published
may prompt some to
challenge the Jim Crow
metaphor I'm invoking here.
I mean, after all,
if segregation
meant separate water fountains
and bathrooms and schools,
then wouldn't
publishing's version
also mean that some areas
would be whites only?
That's a reasonable question.
And I think the
reason people ask
that question is that the term
"segregation" is something
of a misnomer.
In the Jim Crow South,
segregation did not literally
mean the separation of races.
It instead was a way of
regulating the spaces
in which the races interacted.
So African Americans
shared the same spaces
with white Americans, but
they shared them unequally.
As Karen Fields notes,
"Jim Crow on the railways
offered an exemption for the
Afro-American servant attending
her mistress or the
mistress's child."
Comparably, African-American
authors and characters
do find places in genres
outside of history and realism,
but only in a
tokenistic way, kind
of like that servant
on the railway car
or the sole black
friend on a TV sitcom.
So in 2014, the presence
of four dystopian novels
doesn't really
contradict the fact
that dystopia is mostly
closed to writers
and characters of color.
These exceptions not
only prove the rule
but actually provide a
kind of colorblind alibi
for structural racism.
Briefly, four reasons
why diversifying genre
is really important.
First, the institutional
emphasis on history
has the unintended
consequence of implying
that progress in time correlates
with progress towards justice.
It subtly conveys the message
that America's crimes happened
in the past, that the
present is better,
and the future will
be better still.
So for example, there are
very few books about Ferguson
or the Black Lives Matter
movement, the prison
industrial complex
or racist profiling.
So part of diversifying genre
requires a richer selection
of contemporary texts that
address present crises.
In other words, we
don't need fewer realist
and historical texts, we
need more of everything else.
And one reason-- and
this is a second reason
for why we should
diversify genre--
is that a different genre offers
a new perspective on the real.
One risk of so much
historical fiction and realism
is that readers can
get jaded with yet
another realistic historical
novel about the Civil Rights
movement, say.
But novels can explore
history via any genre--
via fantasy, via
science fiction,
dystopia, mystery, horror.
And speculative fiction's
alternate histories
illuminate unexamined
facets of our own history.
An African-American
dystopian novel
shifts the narrative's
center of gravity,
examining power from an angle
that a Caucasian dystopian
novel, which of course is also
known as a dystopian novel,
might neglect.
Genre shifts perspective.
It changes the way we
understand and shakes us out
of our habits of thought.
Diversifying genre can
liberate the imagination.
When we publish, teach, or
read black or other diverse
dystopian novels, fantasy,
or speculative fiction,
we challenge the
unspoken assumption
that certain genres are
mainly for white readers
and white writers.
White children should not
be the only ones encouraged
to see themselves on a
quest in an imaginary world,
grappling with technologies
of the future--
maybe some invented here--
or inhabiting mythological
tales or banding together
to resist a dystopian regime.
We need diversity
among genres in order
to decolonize the imagination.
And to foster literacy
among all children,
we need greater diversity
within and among genres,
because, though a voracious
reader as a child,
the late Walter Dean
Myers recalled the moment
as a teen when, noticing that
there was something missing
in his books, he began to
turn away from reading.
As he writes, quote,
"As I discovered
who I was, a black teenager
in a white-dominated world,
I saw that these characters,
these lives, were not mine."
Years later, James
Baldwin's "Sonny's Blues"
would bring Myers
back to reading
and ultimately lead him to an
acclaimed and prolific career
of writing books
for young people.
But Myers was exceptional.
For many people,
the moment they--
and I'm quoting Myers here--
"lost the potential person
they would become"--
which is such a
powerful and sad idea--
that moment that they
lost that potential person
begins a slide towards
hopelessness from which they
never fully recover.
Obviously, in the fight
for diverse books,
focusing on genre
or on really any
of the areas I've
talked about today
is insufficient
in and of itself.
Structural racism is
a many-headed hydra.
I could have written many
more chapters than the ones
that I did.
So in the book's
conclusion, I offer
a manifesto for anti-racist
children's literature.
And I'll end with
a few highlights
from that, and then we
can go to questions,
or people can
continue their lunch,
or whatever you'd like to do.
So first, recognize that
personal racism is unconscious
and that systemic racism
is typically invisible.
In 1942, Dr. Seuss
drew a cartoon
that he called, "What
This Country Needs
Is a Good Mental Insecticide."
And the cartoon suggests
that if we could just
get our heads fumigated, racism
would no longer afflict us.
While I admire the optimism
of Seuss's metaphor,
racism is not a
bug, it's a feature.
Racism is not aberrant,
it's ordinary.
At the very time that
Seuss drew this cartoon,
he was creating
other cartoons that
stereotype people
of Japanese descent,
inadvertently revealing
his own confusion about how
racism actually works.
Racism is what
Raymond Williams would
have called "a structure
of feeling," which involves
"meanings and values as they
are actively lived and felt."
And there's a lived
and felt component
to racialized thought,
which unconsciously shapes
our emotional responses, our
daily interactions with others,
and our general
experience of the world.
So in any area of life where
emotions inform behavior,
racial structures of
feeling play a role.
In children's book
publishing, this
could be, when evaluating
books for young readers,
is a character sympathetic
or not sympathetic?
Is a novel realistic,
or is it not realistic?
Does the book have
aesthetic merit or not?
Is the manuscript marketable
or not marketable?
Second, don't just
teach tolerance.
Actually respect difference.
As Karen Fields and
Barbara Fields write,
the word "tolerance" is
a well-meaning misnomer.
As they note,
tolerance's shallowness
as a moral or ethical
precept is plain.
"Tolerate thy
neighbor as thyself"
is not quite what Jesus said.
Instead of tolerating
difference,
we should instead
respect difference
by first acknowledging
that it's real.
And then second, we
should recognize that we
have difference in common.
And our differences
are really interesting.
We can learn from each
other if we listen to
and respect different
experiences.
Be aware of the
limits of empathy.
And this is kind
of a white person
advice for this particular one.
White people's
well-meaning attempts
to feel non-white people's
pain often fall short
and can actually be harmful.
So in the field of
children's literature,
educators like
myself, publishers,
consumers must do more
than just sympathize
with under-represented groups.
All of us should instead ask,
how is my action or inaction
causing pain?
How am I responsible?
What can I do?
For people who are
teachers, do you
have just a token Latino or
Latina novel on your syllabus,
or do you have many?
If you're a publisher, are all
of your black children's books
realism, historical
fiction, memoir?
Mark whiteness.
If, while reading, we
encounter a character
whose race is not named,
we just assume whiteness.
But we can take away whiteness's
unmarked power by naming it.
So for writers who
tend to only assign
race or ethnicity to
non-white characters,
you can change that.
If you identify a Native
American third-grader
or a black teacher,
you should also
identify the white football
coach, the white bus driver,
the white guidance counselor.
And in the fall of
2015, Kirkus Reviews
actually started doing this.
They actually
started identifying
the race of everybody.
This is another one
specifically for white people,
and that is that white
people, all of us
must recognize our
complicity in white supremacy
and use our privilege
to fight it.
To quote Robin DiAngelo
again, "White racism
is ultimately a white
problem and the burden
for interrupting it
belongs to white people."
That's partly why
I wrote this book.
All white people need to
acknowledge that you do not
have to actively support white
supremacy in order to benefit
from white supremacy.
All white people benefit
from white supremacy,
whether we want to or not.
And as beneficiaries, we are
also unwitting accomplices.
Fortunately, though unfairly,
our unearned privilege
grants us a more receptive
audience with those whites who
remain unconvinced.
So we have a moral obligation
to use white privilege
to undermine white supremacy.
Obviously, buy diverse
books, and remember
children of all races
need diverse books.
Teach diverse books.
Publish diverse books.
Publishers need to meet the
needs of a population that's
growing more racially
diverse, and not just
because this is the
right thing to do--
although it is-- but
because failing to respond
risks engineering
their own irrelevance.
By 2043, the US population
will be majority non-white,
and if deterred by books that
ignore or stereotype them,
non-white children learn
to read in lesser numbers
or come to understand that
reading is not for them,
then they are less likely
to grow into adults who read
and therefore buy books.
And finally, it's the
responsibility of everybody--
not just authors, writers,
educators, parents of color,
but everybody to
support these efforts.
And we can do this
by being allies,
by being advocates, by
supporting those working
to bring diverse books to
children, by buying them
for our libraries,
teaching them in classes,
giving them to the young
people in our lives.
Racism is resilient,
adaptable, and thriving,
as indicated by the continuing
popularity of white supremacist
leaders--
obviously, Donald
Trump here in the US,
Marine Le Pen in France-- who
did lose the recent election
but still received 34% of
the vote, or twice what
her father received
15 years ago.
The best place to fight racism
is in children's literature
and children's
culture, and we need
to help nurture a
new generation that
is less susceptible to
the follies of bigotry
and the many wounds it inflicts.
Thanks for coming out, and I'm
glad to take questions or not
as you wish.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I grew up
watching "Looney Tunes"
on Saturday mornings.
My dad eventually-- he liked
to do a lot of voice acting
and stuff--
eventually we got
the DVDs so that we
could watch them all the time.
And I don't know
if you're familiar,
but Whoopi Goldberg he did a
little disclaimer in front of--
before the DVDs to say that
this was a different time when
these cartoons were popular, and
that there was a lot of hidden
racism in there as well.
PHILIP NEL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: From your
standpoint, is that--
that disclaimer, is
that on the right track
to presenting the discussion?
Because I know a lot
of people were like,
oh, she didn't need to do that.
PHILIP NEL: I think she
did need to do that,
and I think she could
go even further,
because the racism
of the past continues
to influence the present.
So people watching
those cartoons now
are getting those same messages.
And then the other reason I
think you could go further
is that a common
argument that's made
is, well, people
thought differently
then than they do now,
and so we can't judge them
by the same standards that
we judge people now by.
But here's the thing.
The range of available
opinions does not change.
What changes over time is the
distribution of those opinions.
There were people at the
time those Warner Brothers
cartoons were made who saw
the stereotypes as bad.
Now, they weren't creating
the Warner Brothers cartoons.
But I think the
danger of that is
it has a tendency to excuse
the racism of the past.
And not everybody
thought that way.
I'm going to guess, for
example, that a person who
saw him or herself
caricatured in 1942 or 1953
might feel a little differently
than, say, a white creator who
created that person.
I'm just going to
hazard a guess.
So I think Whoopi
Goldberg's disclaimer
is important to include.
I'd go further.
I'd go further,
because I think you
want to keep this art
alive and out there,
but I also think we need a
complicated relationship to it.
And I think it's
hard for people to--
especially for things they saw
as children-- to develop that,
because you have
affection for it.
It was fun watching those.
Mel Blanc was great.
And culture that is
beautiful, that is enjoyable,
that is marvelous in many
ways can also be damaging.
And I think people need
to have those coexisting
in their minds.
And I know that's hard.
And I think I have
maybe exceeded
the length of my answer
here and gone on too long.
So I'll stop.
AUDIENCE: How could
she go further?
PHILIP NEL: I think
she could go further
by including some resources on
there beyond the introduction.
If it's a DVD, that's
an ideal format for,
let's say, annotating it.
You could have, just as you do
for films, commentary tracks.
You could have
commentary tracks that
work to educate
and not just simply
say how wonderful this was and
how much I enjoyed writing it.
The media we have
available today
offer so many more
possibilities for education.
So the introduction
could do that.
It could say, I invite you
to listen to his audio track
where we talk
about why you might
want to watch this with
questions and not with simply
applause.
But yeah, that's
a great example,
and I'm glad you raised it.
So thanks.
And thanks for
coming, everybody.
It's very nice of you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So it
seems like this is
sort of an interesting and
provocative question you
started off with, and I'm
curious how children answer it.
Is there work-- to some
extent, whether or not
this is a problem is dependent
on how the children who
are reading these books react.
PHILIP NEL: Right.
AUDIENCE: Is there
work and studies
you've done about whether
different races identify more
or less strongly with the Cat
in the Hat, or is this something
that really we're just looking
back and seeing and analyzing?
PHILIP NEL: Yeah--
AUDIENCE: Is that a
thing you can study,
and have you done so?
PHILIP NEL: No, I think
that's an excellent question.
And as you know, the answer
"that's an excellent question"
is the way of a speaker hedging.
And so I'm hedging.
And now I will offer
an imperfect answer
to your excellent
question, which
is that that's the central
question of a lot of children's
literature scholarship.
What do the children think?
And it's tricky to answer
for a variety of reasons.
First of all, you actually
have to do the research
and go interview
individual children,
because individual
children are all different
and all respond
differently, and it's
impossible to generalize
about children,
as it is to generalize
about adults.
And I have not done that
specific research on this.
I have done the research
on the texts themselves,
but I haven't done the
research on the children.
Anecdotally, I can
tell you things,
of people who, when I've talked
about the Cat in the Hat's
minstrel ancestry,
have come up and said,
gosh, he always
disturbed me, and I
think I can now identify why.
Even from when I was a child,
this character disturbed me.
That's anecdotal.
It's not quantitative.
I don't think it
would pass muster
for those of you working in
a major technology company,
I'm just going to guess.
But that's also part of the
reason for writing the book,
is that there are a lot of
ways in which these things are
hidden and unexplored.
You could write 100
chapters on this.
I just wrote five.
But I think a sixth
chapter should
be some kind of quantitative
study, which I did not do.
There are other
studies you could
cite, like on children's
responses to black dolls,
for example.
There are famous studies on
those, in which the children,
even black children prefer the
white doll to the black doll,
and those stories have
been cited as evidence
that they learned racism.
Another way to read
those is that they've
learned which characters get
to do interesting things,
and it's not the
black character.
It's the white character.
But either way, it's an example
of how those attitudes persist
in children's minds.
So there have been studies done.
I have not done a specific
study on "The Cat in the Hat,"
but it's a great idea, and
I think it would really--
we'd learn a lot from
it, and the Seuss people
would not be happy.
But good question.
SPEAKER: Let's give one
more round of applause
to Dr. Philip Nel.
Thank you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]